now I know this a little out of your
hands but there are new powers that be
at DC Studios we have James Gunn Peter
saffron who produced this movie
um I think it would be the biggest loss
to not have a Shazam way stick around so
I'm just curious ideally what you guys
would like to see happen you love this
question I'm really good at this
question huh
what do you mean has anybody else
you'll get everybody here that I'm
poised and professional today I'm really
excited to see what um what what Peter
saffron and James got no it really have
in store for for I mean obviously given
James Gunn posting that uh blueprint of
what the future of DC looks like I'm
hoping and praying to be involved in you
know in any way that I can I I love
being a part of the dceu it's that's
growing up it's been and I really mean
this that I I always kind of wanted to
be I dressed up as Batman as a kid I
dressed up as Superman and I want and
now I'm getting to do it and I have so
much trust and so much faith in Peter
and and James because I I idolize their
work I think they're phenomenal artists
and business people so uh I have nothing
but high hopes that was great that was
awesome
that was awesome
for you what would you love to see
happen
look I mean I you know I I love I love
this movie I love this franchise and I
think it it's so special and has
connected with so many people on such a
personal level so I mean you know we
have the second movie coming out and
we're really excited about it and you
know obviously I'm open to whatever in
the future uh you know I'm just I'm
happy that James Gunn and Peter saffron
have
have taken the shield and uh you know
are have this amazing blueprint like
Jack said and I think yeah anything's
possible and I'm open to whatever and
anything so I'm you know
I'm excited for what the future holds
blessing a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got superpowers
started from the bottom now we're here
we are back
sometimes we're taller we're older we're
older we're taller I stopped growing at
12. how much has changed between the
first Shazam and fury of the Gods
a lot I'd say I'd say a lot I mean
that's happened in between that we
didn't really get to see but we pick up
in a place I feel is very organic to
pick up it's actually the greatest place
we're crossing that threshold into
adulthood from kids uh full of uh Whimsy
and uh and curiosity and and eager to
explore ourselves and then right now
we're at that precipice where it's like
okay but how do we become independent
how do we find ourselves in this weird
mist of uh puberty and uh
um and eventually we we see Billy gain
his footing and uh Freddy doesn't fall
too far behind but uh it's a journey you
know and we get to explore that in the
film without giving any spoilers from
being as big as possible
how is Freddie handling because he kind
of gets his powers towards the end of
the first movie all he ever wanted
they're getting known around
Philadelphia a little bit how is he
handling that I think a little selfishly
but but also you mean again he's he's
still learning everything is a learning
uh opportunity and he's making mistakes
and growing from them eventually he
realizes think at the heart of the movie
the the moral of it is is that family is
first and family will help you overcome
those obstacles if you have people
behind you that are going to help you
lift uh lift you up and access your
greatest potential as a human being I
think that's that's so important and to
remind yourself of that but in the
beginning I think I mean even me even in
my own personal life I've I've tried to
I'd shut people out so I can gain a
semblance of self within me and and be
the best person I could be on my own
because like you know it's like I wanna
I have to do this I don't have to figure
it out on my own you know guys everybody
back off but then you realize yeah of
course like there's people that actually
care about me why should I shut them out
yeah so he's got to learn that and it's
a powerful thing how much do you guys
relate to these characters because they
are you know navigating some similar age
things that you guys are navigating I'm
sure yeah do you yeah I think I mean I
relate to on to a certain extent I
relate with Billy on a lot of things um
in terms of you know family Dynamic um
and stuff because you know we're
teenagers we're growing up and you know
I feel like being a teenager you always
want to you always want to grow up so
fast
um and you know for me it's it's the
opposite like I I want to stay as as
young as possible like I'm not you know
even though I'm 20 you know I I start
think starting to think about moving out
and you know what the future looks like
am I still going to be doing this in you
know 10 years from now hopefully that's
the case but you know um so I think I
can relate with Billy on that because
he's got to be 18 years old I'm about to
become an adult and doesn't know what's
gonna happen he he doesn't know if he
has to be alone for the rest of his life
so you know um so I can definitely
connect with him on that because you
know I'm my family you know I'm not
ready to let my family go and be on my
own and I you know I know it's the same
for him since he's going through you
know all these different obstacles in
his life and you know have gone through
all this adversity and stuff so yeah I'm
so we have the shazamly of course but
then we have this new family coming in
these three sisters these goddesses tell
me about working with Helen Mirren Lucy
Lou Rachel what is it like having them
on set
still hasn't sunk in even when working
with her like I say this all the time I
did work with Helen mirror and that is a
fact that I did get to do that and she
touched my body and I touched hers in a
very professional manner yeah I must
clarify but still it even felt like oh
my God is this really is this Helen
mirror is this really because like I
love her and I've idolized her forever
from Caligula to Catherine the Great
keep going she's spitballing Specter two
uh okay the other one anyway she's
getting fat she's I'm I love her I
really do I have so much love for her
and even before I got to work with her I
idolized her and wanted to work with her
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
look I should be writing all this down
it was almost mind melting or numbing
how kind and real and genuine she was
and how funny she's one of the funniest
people I've ever got to work with her
meat she's so funny she makes me laugh
so hard and uh I love that about her and
also her just she's so welcoming and
I was also welcoming in return it really
helped each other they're very close yes
I feel like every interview I watch Jack
just flirts out something oh dude I'm
actually doing really good today yeah
force a lot of things out that he
doesn't mean to say but don't worry it
comes off charming and
be it prequel series do you have
anything to do with that or is that like
pre I don't I can clear that up right
now I think no so I think it's about
it's about Pennywise his origin story
yeah and then I was like well what if
he's like um
reach out to Annie maybe I don't want to
pry you know I I've been he's been
talking about this for so long but Bob
gray the story Pennywise uh that's so
cool but
Shazam two everybody theater is March
17th yeah go see it get your tickets
foreign